before we get into the video i just want
to shout out this kind old man who
walked into my dojo one day
and promised to help me teach my
students karate
he's even he's even promised to look
after my pet mouse mr fluffles whilst
i'm on holiday yay
[Music]
now the scripts for cobra kai season 3
were finished late last year and filming
for the upcoming entry is due to take
place between january 20th to april 15th
this hopefully means that the series
will release before the end of 2021
but until then i thought i'd break down
what we can expect as well as my
theories on what could happen
if this is your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who puts
the fist
in pacifist and your mother now let's
get into the breakdown
okay so cobra kai season 3 ended with
everyone's favorite sensei john crease
calling out to a close friend to help
him beat both daniel
and johnny wait wait isn't that like the
guy who's looking after my dojo no never
mind
now throughout the season we'd seen the
ins and outs of chris's backstory
namely his time in vietnam during this
he had a couple of allies
namely one that looked very similar to
terry silva but who sadly died before he
could start his own dojo that ended up
terrorizing the entirety of california
now because of the similarities and
looks that he had to terry i've actually
seen a lot of people confused about
why the guy who they thought was silva
died but it's all just been one big
misunderstanding
and the real silver is indeed the person
that we see coming out of his cage
and he's been doing just fine this is
confirmed by the line uttered in the
season
right after this guy is killed in which
the captain says that's your goddamn
mouth
so this is definitely silva and chris
reaching out to him at the end means he
will
be returning similar to the karate kid 3
silva saw himself as owing a life debt
to the character
and this means that all chris has to do
is call out his name
and you know wherever he is he'll come
running i'll stop with his songs
now in karate kid 3 silver was revealed
to have accumulated a fortune since the
war
and during the film he actually bought a
number of dojos
he also tricked daniel and had mike
bonds fight against him
which links back to daniel in the third
season saying that he almost lost to
fear
now because of the ptsd that daniel had
over this i do think that bonds will be
back too
and that there could be a triple threat
for the fourth season
that involves kris silva and the
character this will lead to daniel and
johnny preparing even harder for the old
valley
and the three villains will make the
stakes that much more higher
but who could dany turn to for help well
we already know from season 3 that he's
buried the hatchet with
chosen and i think it would be great if
he chosen to reach out to him
now this would allow terrible this would
allow for the character to come back
and also teach more of the pressure
point technique which i think will
become
essential in the old valley i'd actually
love to see chosen end up with kumiko as
well
and hey that might be a bit cliche but
they're both single so why not
now there are still a lot of theories
floating around that say tori will be
revealed as a relation of either silver
or bonds
the former would mean that she's terry's
granddaughter or if the latter is
correct
then barnes is her dad we now know for
definite that ali
isn't her mother but as her dad was
absent in season three whereas her
mother wasn't
it does leave the possibility open that
mike could be her pops
whenever the silver theory has been
brought up the first response
normally is that tory lives on the
breadline whereas silva is so rich
it's like he was born with a silver
spoon in his mouth eh
now that's a very valid argument but my
response to it would be
well the lads spent millions on dojos
that didn't go anywhere
so maybe now he's broke now though the
ali thing fell flat there are other
theories floating around that tori's mum
might
actually be either jessica from karate
kid 3 or julie pierce aka hilary swank
both cast members still work regularly
and it would be a pretty big get to have
either
especially hillary swank though some say
she's not that hot
now the show did keep tory's mother out
of view so there are some options
however the next karate kid is pretty
universally hated
so whether swank would want to come back
to reprise something that took her a
while to live down
does remain to be seen either way there
are two camps when it comes to tory
some see her as as a sort of last jedi
ray where she's a nobody
and others see her as a rise of
skywalker ray
where she's a palpatine but but also a
skywalker at the end
tori sue did show up out of nowhere with
some amazing karate skills
and though she said she did have
training in martial arts this came
completely out of nowhere
so i'd love to at least see some
training behind this that ties in with
the larger cast of characters
i'm still not sure exactly what reveal i
want for her
but the show is very much rooted in
families such as robbie
sam and so on so it does make sense to
bring in another dynamic with the return
of silver and mike
now there's also the potential that
miguel's father could pop up at some
point
and during the series he's been
described as a very very bad man
this could also open up the door for him
to be bonds as he'd roughly be the same
age as johnny and dany are
so does make some sense it would add
another layer to things as johnny is of
course staying common now
so to have bonds pop up alongside silva
and be revealed to not only be working
with crease
but also miguel's father it just throws
a lot of spanners in the work
imagine if barnes was tori and miguel's
daughter as well
what what a crazy soap opera would turn
into
as well as a terrible theory now another
bad theory is that chris's girl back
home
is actually alive and that he has a
child before approaching the fighting
arena
chris was told by his captain that she
died in a car accident
and this was seemingly confirmed by a
letter which he received before they set
out on the mission now whilst this is
very likely the truth it could also be
possible that it was a dear john letter
and that the captain was simply lying to
him to get him to go
all out in their fight cap was very much
about pushing people's buttons
and enforcing the idea that they were to
show no mercy
so him lying to get chris angry does
line up a lot with what was said
he never pulled the captain out of the
pit so the captain never got the chance
to tell him that he was in fact lying
and i you know you know what we're
clutching that straws here but but let
me just think
now though it's a tenuous theory it
could be revealed that she's actually
alive
and this may be what stops chris turning
into a complete maniac at the end of
season four
wait that is that is the guy looking
after my dojo is
i better get all right the theories are
now now we do know that the old valley
is definitely going ahead once more
and this will be where all sides have
their big showdown in season four
however i think it might actually extend
beyond that and after the winner is
announced
likely miguel that robbie will try and
attack him after the fact
and that it will be johnny who has to
bring him back from crease
robbie has pretty much always been on
the precipice of being bad
and i think that the key to winning him
back lies with johnny finally accepting
that he has to put his son before
himself
sid was always someone that viewed
johnny as a person he had to bail out
rather than his son i think johnny is
very similar in his view of robbie
that means that he's the key to bringing
him back from the brink
i think that it will very much be the
way that the fourth season ends
now as for johnny and dany's gym i'd
love to see it be called
miyagi kai or or maybe eagle fang
wait that's take anyway let me know your
thoughts on on what the name should be
and if you have any other theories then
comment below and let me know
don't forget that on the 30th of january
we're giving away three copies of the
hobbit and lord of the rings 4k box
set to our subscribers all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winner of last month's competition
are on screen now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
75 of the best easter eggs in the season
which will be linked on screen right now
we went through the entire thing
and pointed out some of the coolest
details so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want something else
to watch
and without the way thank you for
sitting through the video i've been paul
and i'll see you next time take care
peace